mr dumplings
[Music]
what we're gonna do right here is go
back
[Music]
what's up
will that be all
actually
i really like the shirt that you're
wearing do you have any of those around
no we don't have it here it's only
available at crowdershop.com
it's this nazi show that i watch
ironically everybody who has anything to
do with it is a racist
so you're ironically racist wearing a
swastika it's hilarious
stupid
in that case.com
[Applause]
head over to the shop support the fight
and buy some cool breads
it's the tits pajamas.com
[Music]
[Music]
thanks
[Music]
strangers
[Music]
hmm
that was a damn good sip oh nice
impressed slurpee slurpee
my headphones my ears are all all messed
up right now just so you guys know i am
very sick oh i'm a better better sixer
but uh still test negative for covet
dang it that's a shame which is just
slower here you tested negative for
coconut or black i did too so
something's been going and you were sick
yeah we've all so it turns out that you
can still get sick and it not be i
didn't know that was possible that's
rare i know what that's a good thing
this should be that being said it's
important to remember
this is a pandemic of the index yes yes
so this we're going to be talking about
that today quite a bit that this is a
pandemic of the unvaccinated what level
of protection is offered to you with the
vaccine according to international
studies according to cdc according to
the world health organization according
to uh cohort studies according to
meta-analyses from mayo clinic from
israel we're going to get into that
because this is something that has been
repeated uh not by our president and i
know this a little bit late but our last
show was thursday but i will say this
before we move on
some of the things that uh former vice
president joe biden said
and my wife said this was surprising
because i've always been an optimist
when it comes to the united states of
america you can go back to when obama
was president you can go back to some
defeats that donald trump ran into and i
always said look we have checks and
balances it's going to get better
i've never had the hair on the back of
my neck stand up
and chills go down my spine
as when joe biden said it's not about
your freedoms it's not about your choice
and our patience
is wearing thin
this is a really really scary time
this is unprecedented
and i really hope that we're not looking
back
uh at
this moment as the moment that the
america we knew ceased to be and i'm not
being melodramatic about it i've never
said that on this show before that
speech to me and that mandate was
absolutely a line in the sand and that
has nothing to do with your personal
choice to get vaccinated or the science
regarding covet which is of course a
serious condition we talk about that
we'll be talking about the vmas we have
my favorite little jewish gentleman and
i am his least favorite gentile ben
shapiro on the show that's right that's
fantastic and shapiro on the show do you
know a true story about ben shapiro
before we move on he thought he was like
his hair was thinning here a little bit
and uh
my wife said like well i'm just wearing
down from the hat that's exactly what it
was
and my wife was there my wife said i
think but that's where you wear your uh
is it kippah yeah he's like yeah yeah
it's a camper yamaka either way same
thing so she was like i think that's
just what it is he was like you could
see he was so relieved
because his hair was fine everywhere
else so i really think that's what it is
he's always been a friend of mine even
if i disagree with him on some stuff but
um before
before we get to that gerald a how are
you i am better than you yeah sorry
about it so far yeah i didn't i did not
i was not patient zero for the office
here it was not me it was you it was my
son well we need to find a gay male
flight attendant and uh quarter black
how are you i feel a lot better a lot
better now that you have i'm so glad it
wasn't sickle cell and dave landau who's
going to be at the albany funny bone
september it's genetics it is september
24th 25th that's correct uh hoy
everybody and i think calling it a gay
male flight attendant's a bit redundant
[Laughter]
fair point are we in trouble already no
no grammatical nazi i'm saying that
and also incredibly homophobic i agree
yes that's what i'm saying i had a male
flight attendant and i won't be
redundant so show on the blanks um
say would you like some extra water and
i just thought this was pre-pandemic
when we could get water and he just off
but as he offered it to me i was taking
it but he kind of went for my hand yeah
like no i don't want to hold a handle
no
no i just spilled this everywhere oh
jeez oh it's so off i don't know why
kleenex is not as absorbent as paper
towels when you think about it so yeah
you know what the paper towel is but
it's really enough soda on the counter
let's make something less effective for
fleming snot
yeah that's not really what it's for
yeah well
tell that to my sock drawer so at this
point
he played it
perfectly we've all heard about the
texas uh abortion ban right yeah
and now the left's penalty
for the texas abortion ban um is uh no
more sex but um you really can't put you
can't let that sink in until you
actually you know put the faces to the
slogan until you know you you see it
grizzly how it affects
real folks
that's right
general strike 2021 ladies
boys and misogynists don't get any
flowers
i know that's right and you don't get to
go to the chocolate factory ladies we
should not [ __ ] another man i think we
should go on a sex strike can we get
that in writing think about it like full
stop no sex
yellow cheese single man
i'm just saying historically strikes
have worked
okay cool we're not having sex women are
dealing with this
no sec
abortion
should be free of cost so that's just
the child
that's the charlie the chocolate factory
when she put on the net without my
daughter uh
she's gonna throw us off that's like
expect alfred molina to come in and
backhand her uh no sex strikes don't
work because uh unless all prostitutes
are on sex strike with you
not to mention uh women you want to have
sex with yeah i suppose
including uh there's a shortage in a lot
of things but not uh not the uh not the
polymer used for blow up dolls yeah you
know that gerald b no this is just this
would be so offensive to me you know
women i we have so many questions today
but i really want to know to women out
there and we have a significant amount
of women who watch this show it always
surprises me because i'm like
this would be so offensive to me as a
woman
the idea that you can't have sex
and be responsible no abortions no sex
okay let's just say that you're totally
against it you don't even understand the
science of the fact that you're ending
another life that you are terminating
another heartbeat not your own you don't
have two hearts that's a fact that's
what this bill is
but
at this same point
that they are just saying well you know
what abor if you do that we can't
possibly be expected to monitor
monitor our sexual activity are sexual
comings and goings there's no way yeah
my issue with it is they always say that
they have the equal sex drive you're
basically saying that you don't want sex
as much as men and when you say that men
women weaponize sex that's supposed to
be offensive right and now you're
weaponizing sex right yeah well in this
case they want people
to believe they're weaponizing it's like
did you see how i weaponized sex look
how little sex i'm having guys
everyone's like okay i was having sex
with you anyways keep it up we just
assumed
[Laughter]
i'm not gonna have sex out of you and me
and i am not having sex oh
yeah that one girl looked like gabriel
and gray iglesias in a frightening week
i don't want to have sex with you oh
deal okay fluffy
yeah
he's taking a peek off that's fine
speaking of sex and i'm not fed them
fluffy
either i'm an old fuddy which is
possible
yeah or
we have reached a state in our culture
of complete and absolute degeneracy
yesterday the vmas happened the video
music works for the initiating they have
videos still yeah i guess
basically youtube video and uh they uh
boy we we've come a long way from you
know elvis's gyrating hips and i want to
hold your hand right that's what he's
like i wanna i wanna hold your hand
like well what is he saying whereas now
we're pantomiming sodomy in a shower
uh slippery slope i guess yes well also
don't run in the shower yeah don't don't
drop in the group sex shower with
anthony fauci taking notes they still
just showed elvis from the waist up
though yeah yeah because his hips were a
bit too much
and then tom jones they showed him from
the waist down almost exclusively
[Laughter]
to this contract nothing going on down
there so this is what happened if aliens
accidentally intercepted
a transmission a broadcast of the vmas
they would immediately become hostile a
trans transmission yes
we call them uh
cis trends
i don't know i guess it depends on the
wavelength of the i don't know i'm not
sure 5d is giving you cancer okay um
here's what what's the first clip that
we have
it little nausea wait the first clip is
is lil noss yeah oh this is the guy this
is the guy by the way who uh sold
sneakers with vials of blood yeah uh
while doing a
music video where he was giving satan a
lap dance also didn't get
the funniest part didn't get permission
from nike to put vials of blood in their
shoes he basically just went and bought
a bunch of nikes and then was just
putting test tubes in them and like
because you can't do that
but i'm gay though like putting these
condoms and reebok pumps just
[Music]
so anyways
this is the vmas lil nosse's performance
pantomiming having sex in the shower
[Applause]
i'm glad my father's dead
there's no reason anybody should have to
see this from that generation and also
he praised himself over twitter for the
rin say when saying video of the year ah
suck my
c-o-c
listening on audio
which is a really weird reaction if
someone was performing fellatio
it's like what are you angels with
filthy souls get down on your knees and
tell me you love me
we should have seen it coming a little
nice i'm over the moon for you so
let's just think this is a one-off
unless you think this is a one-off
another female singer and i don't know
normandy
who even knows at this point you know
what they just do is they they they
spell something and they mispronounce it
to try and accuse you of being too white
right right right like it's nomani oh
okay
i couldn't have possibly known that yeah
nor
alexa uh let's just roll a clip of this
it's just degeneracy all around
[Music]
so that's a woman on a cross
fish gurney pretty sure that's what they
were going for it was the cross you know
yeah
thanks dave you're very welcome
[Music]
[Applause]
now now look first off i'm just confused
of how it's music yeah
i'm just confused as to how it's art
what is this not to mention the
questions of consent
we stormed the beaches of normandy for
that yeah seriously if hitler had two
brain cells to rub together he just
would instead of those uh instead of
those machine guns he just would have
had those people right up there in the
beach
and the allies were like all right we're
out of here are they just bomb it from
the air the scots would have grabbed
their like little bicycle helmets that
were completely impractical like we're
going home boys yeah there's no reason
to fight for this they they're humping
each other on gurney crosses these
nations too far god and they even have
the helmets
they don't not the full healer but they
they have hitler ours just protect the
top of my head unless someone's shooting
me straight down
they're all billy connolly
[Laughter]
and this is well you know what i i'll
talk about this later i went to a
wonderful steak dinner with my wife
sweetheart i hope you're feeling better
she caught it too oh no and uh there
isn't there was a lot of
older women now trying to dress this way
there was an epidemic of pardon
if you have kids here of old fat [ __ ]
and i mean this there was it said a 40
year old birthday party and
uh there's no way it was 40. i have
never seen
more totality of breasts
outside of an actual naked woman yeah
and i mean these women were big these
women they were about they were lining
up it was a brazilian steakhouse that
the sat they're at the salad bar trying
to keep up appearances love and they
have cell they have skirts where you can
see their panties and cellulite that
looks like bullet wounds i'm looking for
the exit channel and then this is on a
shelf one lady had this skin-tight dress
and was wearing a thong so the spillover
was like it was trying to escape and you
know what here's the thing we've just
told everybody that all women have
earned all clothes that's not true it's
not true you haven't earned the right to
wear those clothes
just like i haven't earned the right to
you know go to the steakhouse salad bar
and a thong well i don't think you
should
you might as well i go on askless chaps
yeah but that's free the ball the way i
eat
i need to hurry to the restroom dave
goes to a different steakhouse yes
it is brazilian though this doesn't just
end by the way with with vmas it would
be one thing if it's the vmas but you
know we talked about cuties on netflix
yeah and i will say this this does
matter of course this is we're talking
about the culture at large the hyper
sexualization of children you look at uh
uh lil nas and you who's you know sodomy
in the shower you look at that where
she's humping somebody which by the way
women can't hump like that's just stupid
yeah it's biologically it's nonsensical
i don't know the rhythm but now
this and i just heard from my friend who
went to go see jungle cruise which he's
no longer a friend but
this is the new t-mobile ad that you
will see at movie theaters at a
children's movie and we have the whole
thing but we won't have to watch the
whole thing just so you see that we're
not editing it out of context you could
take your kids you could put on your
internet blocker you could put on your
parental controls on the tv you can make
sure that vmas has some kind of a word
block and set to google alerts but you
go to the movie theater and with your
five-year-old kid you still see this
[Laughter]
girl i'm busy i'll call you back
oh
now that was extra oh you want extra
i'm about to unfold your world honey
what do you think they're gonna
transport to a tea party oh it's sex
dominatrix flip fold snap clack touch
screen sleek black you me you wish flip
phone who this oh so long did that wack
phone now work get your clack on she
back
i bet not your family inviting you for
thanksgiving
i just collect
it's a flip phone by the way what i hate
about this is a presumption like it used
to be you know like
you know someone said it's the sex
symbol you know just sort of tosses
their and gives you a look you're like
oh we get it but this person like you
know you want it
no no no no no
the most offensive part is that you
presume that anyone is even remotely
interested outside of twisted twisted
folks who think this should be shown
from children i have a question though
and this is an honest question was that
a woman
no no ah okay i was confused wesley
dykes in demolition
traveled back through time to
ruin your childhood sure
wait no i'm thinking of time cop is
there travel in demolition
that he gets sort of he's frozen right
right he's frozen it comes out later
well you know what maybe someone can
freeze me put me next to walt disney's
head and swastika you don't want to be
around there was a kid in a time cop
shirt when i was in high school and he
went to fight my friend
and he was just about to step up to him
they were going to fight in the hallway
and then my friend sean walks out of
this classroom looks at me and goes is
that a time cop shirt and everybody just
laughed at him and it ended the fight
fight over
and you lose nothing ends up in pointing
out your terrible shirt
takes it off there's a blood sport two
shirts shoot dang it oh man i [ __ ]
stop buying these but i love joking i'm
so glad you take it off played trinity
this was a bad choice
why do i wear so many t-shirts steel
magnolias is the next one we're like
that one's good we all like
fried green tomatoes
fights back on you're crying so here's
something too that does look when people
talk remember that when we used to talk
about this and they would say oh no
one's coming for your kids look i don't
of course there's a certain percentage
of the population that's gay kids who
are gay they of course if my kids were
gay love them just the same as anybody
else but recent insider study found that
there's a 222
increase in the number of lgbtq
characters in children's cartoons
programming the kind of stuff that we
see here now keep in mind that they make
up about anywhere from two to five point
six percent of the population
um but
more than like eight to fourteen percent
of couples on screen so when people talk
about representation look there is over
representation in the media and it's
designed to make people think that
not i'm not just talking about lgbtq but
look this is
look at the vmas it was it was the lgbtq
party yeah yeah they weren't they
weren't there are no lgbtq boating
magazines i mean they're playing to
their base so nobody else is watching
that the vmas i would like to see lg the
lgbtq advocate go out there and pull an
elliott smith miss misery from the
oscars just in a white suit at a piano
and be like by the way love dick bye
like oh
you have no idea what a good role model
says click clack
it's like it's enough yeah elton john
did it for 30 years 40 50. yeah it's old
people yeah feathered boa who really
cares yeah because he was great he was a
fantastic performer talented man great
great this is like the only defining
character now or characteristic i should
say of artists it's like oh it's because
i'm pushing this envelope not because i
can sing dance play whatever it is it's
just that i'm that well we've gone so
far back now where we've we've told kids
that they should find their self-esteem
and nothing but the superficial yeah if
you were to watch the vmas you wouldn't
think oh oh you know what i should go
out and be a good person and this no you
would just go oh this is what makes me
valuable right it's the same thing with
a lot of young women today they don't
just say hey if you're morbidly obese
maybe you're really smart maybe you're
really talented at something else and
maybe you should be healthy and lose
weight it's no no you should find pride
in your identity in something skin deep
it's this reverse kind of of of
narcissism that that they don't
understand you're breeding kids who
simply feel entitled to have self-esteem
because of how they look regardless of
how offensive they may look yeah well
don't next time you blame the patriarchy
for sexualizing women i'm just going to
have exhibit a but we didn't do this
called fact well this is what happens
when you withhold sex
all of a sudden lil na starts look it's
like it's like when you're on an island
and your friend starts turning into a
hot dog yeah you're like hmm
by the way
you can follow me on the instagram and
apparently on tick tock because we're
still trying to fight the degeneracy
where it lies
for as long as they allow us and uh hit
the notification bell guys if you're on
youtube that's the best thing not the
subscription thing but hit the
notification bell so you know when we're
broadcasting on this channel the stephen
crowder channel it's monday through
thursday 10 a.m eastern yeah way to
start late today because youtube was
screwing with us uh and of course we'll
be taking a live chat at mug club for an
additional 45 minutes all right another
thing before we get to the vaccine crap
over the weekend there was a evander
holly field the tour belfor fight which
uh
whoever sanctioned this should be lined
up and shot no they're lining their
pockets with cash yes all it is but we
should shoot holes through the cash in
their pocket through their crotch i've
seen movies where the the the cash
actually stops the bullet is that that's
true i don't know that i watch buster's
yeah
i have no idea it's just all rocky five
yes you're not gonna win you're not yeah
just as you just beat up an old man yeah
a 58 year old man you're holding missing
an ear and i thought he was actually
going to do better because he was a
boxer but anyway he was amazing uh
donald trump was there commentating we
had his son on the show if you want to
see last thursday yeah and uh the crowd
was seen chanting and this is not a
political rally this was a fight night
right right this could this could easily
be just a random sampling of the country
chanting we love trump uh followed by a
chant about the most popular president
in history 80 million votes joe biden
this happened organically
special warriors
[Applause]
that's
[Laughter]
well great a great honor and thank you
very much thank you everybody very much
we love our country i love our country
thank you very much well i know 81
million people that aren't there yeah
apparently they decided to take the day
off from fun
here's another patriotic chant of making
the round at college football games and
here's the thing at multiple games yeah
it's almost as it's almost like a
movement it's like uh it's like owling
or planking or the ice bucket challenge
only they chant this
[Applause]
i love college football hilarious
[Applause]
michigan
oh yeah
you know when u of m is chanting this
it's there's hope right
that's ole miss i think i expect it
there well yeah it keeps going there's
more oh there's more we have a ton more
we can probably i think there's
wasn't their first black player in like
78 yeah
yeah and then they said uh oh we uh we
uh our team is bad yeah we just oh
at what point does brothers cost us wins
what i love about this is these are
young people doing this those are
student sections yeah not typically
known to be super solid core republicans
like you tend to be a bit liberal in
college yeah pretty sure
ann arbor michigan pretty liberal yeah
relatively liberal but a lot of people
go to the games or people who are coming
in from outside the actual city that's
true there's a lot of people who live in
the city you're like oh they're having a
football game i hate how much it
stimulates the economy
activities
the only reason anybody would go to what
lansing or ann arbor and that state from
michigan state michigan it's barbaric i
only go to lansing to burn something
down i lived in lane
yeah and i burn stuff down yeah yeah you
usually end up burning down your own
life in lansing you do that's what it is
awful awful place lancing mission and i
say this as a michigander there's no
reason to go there outside of protest
well it's not really a protest if you
win or lose a basketball game you set a
car on fire
just like montreal
hey man did the habs win yeah they were
going to riot and loot hey man did the
habs win no they lost the sea damn we're
going to riot and loot
look at all these matches i got the
gasoline today's gonna be fun it's gonna
be a good i i watched this uh
this is how i learned about communism as
a kid how i learned about anarchy i
should say i've told the story before
but uh the montreal canadiens i believe
lost the playoffs so there was a big
riot this used to happen in montreal all
the time people can find a quick search
and this was on television they're
covering the riots and this one guy
breaks it was either a levi's or a gap
window he breaks the window and he grabs
a whole stack of jeans right and he gets
up on a cop car and goes
and then this slightly bigger guy takes
one step up the cop car and just grabs
his stack and walks away with it
hey hey
and as a kid i was laughing like what do
you think was gonna happen anarchy the
slightly bigger guy takes the stuff that
you stole from somebody else how it
works they just gathered it for him
essentially
all right you know let's talk about that
next time the the uh biden droning the
wrong person because it happens all the
time uh here's something with anthony
fouch the expert
that's sad it happens all the time but
right now we have to we have venture
peers it's just funny that it's so
common you just glaze over something so
terrible you're like i did another
whoops of daisy with the drones he did
another whoops of daisy killing the
wrong guy who was uh not working for the
government but you know what hey people
either care that our countrymen were
hung out to dry or you don't
at this point i don't know that i can
really convince you yeah that's true
seeing record number of resignations
from the military right now
so fauci of course the expert on um
nothing
uh he this surprised me this was over
the weekend he had no answer and this is
something i've always talked about with
the media we're going to get into the
pandemic of the unvaccinated here uh he
had no answer
as to why which is being recommended by
doctors across the country and i've
always thought it was just a little bit
odd because it does seem like we're a
new territory i've never
been requested by a healthcare
practitioner myself to be vaccinated for
something that i've already had not
talking about seasonal flus because that
changes
and this is just anecdotal but dr fauci
was asked on cnn what they thought was a
softball i think it was cnn maybe it was
abc i have no idea yeah cnn it was cnn
um
people who were previously infected with
covid why they should get the vaccine
yeah
here's his non-answer what are people to
make of that so so as we talk about
vaccine mandates there are i get calls
all the time people say i've already had
covid i'm protected and now the study
says maybe even more protected than the
vaccine alone no not maybe they'll
absolutely get the vaccine how do you
make them
you know that's a really good point
sanjay i don't have a really firm answer
for you on that one
to discuss
regarding the durability of the response
the one thing the paper from israel
didn't tell you is whether or not as
high as the protection is with natural
infection what's the durability compared
to the durability of a vaccine so it is
conceivable that you got infected you're
protected but you may not be protected
for an indefinite period of time okay
hold on a second is that and do you you
that's okay you can go joe because you
were talking about the world health
organization
i don't know anyone anyone in the
legitimate medical community who is
saying that natural immunity is less
robust than the vaccination yeah i've
only heard that natural immunity is
obviously more effective and here's
again what you're not hearing
is how many people who've had covid have
gotten it again we did we did a story on
that about a year in and there were zero
there may be more than zero now there
are but certainly not nearly as many as
people who've been vaccinated how do you
know because they've talked about making
boosters mandatory because
that immunity was wearing off not so
with people who have natural immunity
now i'm not saying if you haven't had
kova that the vaccine makes this is a
decision that you have to make but to
act as though natural immunity could in
any way
be less effective in the vaccine you are
not following the science it's not maybe
it's not allegedly it's not supposedly
supposedly it's of course natural
immunity is more effective than what you
get in the vaccine period we all know
that now answer the question dr fauci
and he can't no he can't and and what we
know is that natural immunity actually
you've trained your body i'm not a
doctor so i'm not going to get too
specific i don't want to get us kind of
kicked off of you here
the the body is going to i'll just say
it this way the body will fight a virus
that it's already had
differently than a vaccine will that
does not kill the virus this vaccine has
never been about killing the virus it's
just about making your outcome better
making sure you don't die making sure
you don't have as high of a
hospitalization well they change the
definition of protection that's true
that's true but then end of vaccine with
a straight face dr fauci pivots and says
but we don't know how long that's going
to last i'm like i don't know how long
has the vaccine efficacy lasted yeah
eight
take your booster and uh wash your hands
and like yeah so you're telling me what
you think here is what he said i think
that you getting coveted will actually
have a shorter duration of efficacy than
eight months roughly that's what he's
kind of thrown out there because he's
like well we just don't know how long
it's gonna last yeah maybe it's gonna be
better for you you're saying it's less
than eight months or right about there
anyone find me any science anyone out
there this is comment comment comment we
have all of our links available
lightworkcredit.com anyone out there do
you have any published scientific papers
that by the way meet the same stringent
requirements that you have for any other
drugs or any other medication for any
other vaccine that suggests
even for a moment that vaccination
immunity is more long-lasting or more
effective than natural immunity well why
do you need a booster then
well just don't dave you just ruined it
well i just i'm sorry i didn't mean to
do your work for you i'm just so
his answer was just confusing every time
anybody asks him anything he just throws
out words until halfway into what he
says you go i don't care
now i'm just going to hit my fouchy head
and see what it is yeah it doesn't
matter you can use a magic eight ball
and it's more effective than him well it
just makes common sense i'm hoping that
what happens here is that facebook
twitter youtube all the people out there
who are censoring misinformation will
actually censor fouchy because the who
just came out and said who that they
don't necessarily they say that we
should pause the the booster
conversation right now they're right not
sure wh this is not completely
definitive but this is what the wh said
which dr fauci just a couple of days by
the way also the who said the lockdowns
were catastrophic right yeah yeah
so it just depends on you know at that
point then you have people at facebook
like oh do we go with a little h2o or
cdc oh i just wish they could have a
meeting behind our backs
they'll get it together yeah they'll get
in the same room and they'll figure it
out and by the way this is what's also
important if the goal is to get us back
to normal if the goal is to get people
off of perpetual welfare if the goal is
to get businesses back into operation if
the goal is to try and eliminate the
staggering record high inflation that
we've seen quarter over quarter then the
science matters if you've had the virus
and your natural immunity is more
effective than the vaccine in other
words we do not have right now a
protocol we do not have a plan in this
country that even takes into account
yeah whether you've had covid or not at
all you can't do that for joe biden's
thing over 100 employees you have to get
tested or vaccinated it doesn't say oh
and if you've had it you just have to
show proof it doesn't matter how do you
get back to normal if you have a
mandatory vaccine and a president coming
out saying what he said that's an honest
question no i think that has to be
thrown off youtube you know what just
watch your taste out of your mouth and
go watch some little i'm sorry you're
right go watch some lil nos and remember
america in the days of apple pie and
white picket fences and sodomy in the
showers
this didn't stop by the way uh dr fauci
from signaling his support for mandatory
vaccines for all air travel in public
schools again regardless of whether
you've had the virus or not and what's
important here too is i was watching cnn
this morning and it's not just what you
see in the news it's what they don't
tell you
that's what's very important in other
words if ever you feel as though you're
getting something incomplete wait hold
on a second what is the immunity like
what's that story what is the immunity
if you already have the virus they'll
never bring it up they'll never matter
it's a non-issue same thing with this
doctor on cnn who i was watching this
morning doctor dr lyanna wen is her name
you've probably seen this crazy
communist uh i and i don't have evidence
for that but if i had to bet you're
probably banging eric swalwall a little
hyperbole
um she said is an authoritative source
on cena she's cnn's medical analyst and
washington post contributing columnist
there you go that'll get some that'll
get a nice seat on a board at a think
tank here's her
this morning i believe talking need to
start looking at the choice to remain
unvaccinated the same as we look at
driving while intoxicated and you have
the option to not get vaccinated if you
want but then you can't go out in public
because when you go out in public you
have the potential of infecting other
people with a potentially deadly disease
just potential potential you can choose
to drink in private if you want but if
you get behind the wheel of a car and
can endanger other people there is an
obligation by society to prevent you
from doing that so i think the what
president biden did today is exactly
right to say that the vaccinated should
not have to pay the price for the
so-called choices of the unvaccinated
anymore so-called choices your point
chris i definitely um wished that he had
also announced some type of proof of
vaccination okay good remember hey
remember by the way when they they said
even dr fauci maybe someone can bring
this up from the control room because
just like masks he said you're not going
to mandate people to get vaccinated yeah
he said you know if the people won't you
can't force them to right now saying
this so-called choice
um you mean free i mean whenever i'm
unvaccinated i tend to you know swerve
all over hit people on bikes fight a cop
here's something else the reason it's a
bad analogy you actually can drink at
home and then drive yeah provided you're
not over the legal limit and you're not
inebriated people do it all the time in
some states i don't know if it still is
but in some states you could drink while
in the car because the point wasn't is
there alcohol in the car it's are you
inebriated does it harm your mental
faculties are you unable to uh to make
reactions in time so it's not a valid
comparison also let's compare that risk
to that of covet if you're making a risk
assessment program the whole thing here
is this is always done under the guise
of the greater good saying well it's not
really a choice because your decision
affects me well remember when people
were told your decision to not be
vaccinated doesn't affect that because
the vaccinated can't catch it right yeah
that's what that's what we were until
the definition was changed
well plus i've done some research and i
do know the effects alcohol has on the
body yes oh so as opposed to the answers
we're getting for the vaccine you
followed the science he did i failed
he did field research yeah i did i did a
field sobriety research and then woke up
in a field
what is this
90 days in community service for a
vaccine
where's my pants
and here's something else too just to
give you an idea this person who's a
medical expert and this is also why
medical experts
first off they may not necessarily be
medical experts i've done some research
into leanna wen here and this is someone
who's presented to you on cnn is
unbiased no this is not this is a
leftist activist of course uh my problem
is not if you're left if you're right
it's if you lie to me about it she's
dishonest about it she's not forthcoming
about it and cnn certainly is not
forthcoming about it uh but let's assume
that she was an unbiased doctor let's
assume that fauci was an unbiased doctor
that also doesn't make them
constitutional lawyers right yeah
this is this is an issue that people
need to understand is these people have
a lane and their only lane their only
tool is a hammer so they look at every
problem as a nail that's why you get to
the point where the cdc says we have the
authority to uh screw landlords and tell
people they don't have to pay rent what
why a public health crisis but that's
unconstitutional that's a violation of
my property rights i don't know anything
about that i just know the vaccine
and there's a lipid layer the virus
micro the point is it's just scientific
for you uh we're gonna take your
property
so she also said right here case in
point that she claimed unvaccinated
americans actually as far she knows
don't have a right to travel
but there's an even bigger reason too
which is i think we really may need to
make it clear that there are privileges
associated with being an american that
if you wish to have these privileges you
need to get vaccinated travel and having
the right to travel in our state it's
not a constitutional right as far as i'm
as far as i know to um to to to
borderline and so saying that if you
want to stay unvaccinated that's your
choice but if you want to travel you
better go get that vaccine oh well it's
funny that she should mention that huh
uh because there actually is a right to
travel oh really established for the
1999 case signs versus row a lot of rows
in these big cases yeah what's up with
all these romans is this is row showing
up the supreme court like bro quit megan
look at show it up at her higher courts
the hell are you doing again so
i'm sorry tubing just distracts me
in the battle i could never look at that
guy and he's just thinking like i was
just done talking so i can start
i've got a highlight reel of the pmas
and a bottle of lubriderm that won't
take care of itself so i'm harder than
astrophysics
so waiting for this idiot to quit
babbling
so go just go back to eric's web dungeon
i like his farts
so the 1999 case signs versus row it
includes the rights of citizens to move
freely between states so she says
there's no right to that as far as i
know okay well we've established that
all the sources are available at
cutter.com you don't know yeah it is a
right and this is the issue when they
say well no we don't know about the
rights therefore they don't exist well
hold on a second actually
[Applause]
hold on a second wait a second the cdc
doesn't have those are private property
rights you can't force
you can't force a someone who actually
owns that property to to have to allow
someone to stay there rent free for nine
months that's their property that's a
violation of actual property i don't
know what property rights are la la la
la la and on cnn it's good enough for
everyone there i think that was chris
cuomo in that last month like there's no
right to travel uh in america as far as
i know it was like good point yeah
nobody [ __ ] that there's not one
person to go
wrong well you didn't have to do that
just hedge it and say well you know i
don't know if there is but i it kind of
sounds like there might be because we
can do it so what are you saying every
road that goes into another state has to
have a checkpoint where you show your
papers like i'm vaccinated i get to go
through here or i'm not vaccinated i
guess i got to turn this conditional
freedom is just well there's a reason we
don't put doctors in charge of
everything we said this at the very
beginning of this there's a reason that
they advise the president because the
president has to take into consideration
a ton of other things like i don't know
having an economy and a life there's a
reason you don't put doctors in charge
of hospitals most of them aren't even
employees you know that a lot of them
are contractors other doctors yeah
depending on the hospitals you have
business managers managers
there yeah this is something that
doesn't mean that they know how to
manage an economy no no and also freedom
they they yeah i can't understand that
that's what that's any freedom i don't
care it's a constitutionally recognized
right to travel and dr leanna wen who's
completely unbiased at cnn says not as
far as i know and she can't even be
bothered just to run a quick google
search like when barack obama or joe
biden say seven or seven cents on the
dollar like oh well that's been debunked
by every single economist that's why we
know it's a lie by the way she's a
completely honest uh scientist cited by
cnn who just so happened to be the head
of planned parenthood just so you know
while we're talking about science hey
where does life begin what does planned
parenthood believe
if it's past the the six week mark do
you have two hearts what about when a
lot of abortions are performed in the
second trip does a woman have 20 fingers
does a woman have 20 toes does a woman
have a vagina and a penis if this
happens to be in her body her body her
choice where does that end planned
parenthood says we don't care about the
science anymore it needs to be
taxpayer-funded on-demand absolutely
period and the really funny part about
lyanna wen is that in january of 2020 i
don't want to assume that she's uh
carrying the water for the chinese
communist party
yeah she wrote this article
cnn uh just to be clear leona when
youtube just so you don't auto correct
us we have the source
baltimore sun leanna when wrote this
that the flu is more lethal than covid
in 2020 again when did she write this
2020. i guess the science changed yeah
maybe the science changed that's fine
but the constitution doesn't sweetheart
so there's a life lesson for you uh and
uh you know you're probably not gonna
get it from tuban no you just hear the
hand of one you just hear the sound of
one hand
different life lessons they've gone to
full body shots of him all the time it's
never from the waist up anymore it's
like no no to protect ourselves we have
the full tube and shot we need to cover
all of it they need to make sure
they don't let them stand until they
make sure the cameras are both of his
hands have to be on the screen at all
times like they can't have anything go
below just the level of hypocrisy though
of him existing on that platform still
is amazing to me always it's always the
best when they have to talk about some
scandal like harvey weinstein or me yeah
yes or like and uh cnn legal analyst
jeffrey tube and he's just like
well when i went through it it really
sucked uh to be on the other end of that
well i don't have a a ruined ficus like
harvey weinstein yes
that i was on a plane yesterday and
there was a guy i'm not kidding it's a
white guy with black toes i don't know
what it was i don't care for it and that
was peeling
like and he was wearing flip-flops
because why wouldn't you want to show
the world that
but if that guy's allowed on a plane i'm
allowed on a plane
oh i mean that is scary
like i kept looking over at it i was
like what
if jeffrey tuban is allowed on a plane
the unvaccinated should be allowed on
planets he pulls out his laptop
everybody's like well it's going to be a
mess yeah
all right this is another segment we
have here before we move on to the
pandemic of the unvaccinated uh and ben
shapiro we're going to do a new segment
here called curious coincidences where
we um we simply have to point out crazy
coincidences and i want to be clear here
i want to be very clear yeah that occur
in daily life because a lot of people
sometimes think it's fate a lot of
people think that there's a connection
yeah no these are coincidences that have
occurred um
that are completely unexplainable and
are totally unrelated so in no related
fashion whatsoever coincidences that we
just find interesting because the
universe
wills them to be
so let's go to curious coincidences
[Music]
just to be clear completely unrelated
yep
i have no idea how this happens
we're crazy just the cosmos yeah someone
gets sick it just happens
so did you know that the emergency use
uh authorization of covid19 vaccines so
it's the mercer's emergency
authorization act it requires that there
be no safe or existing treatments
so the difference between a normal
approval is there needs to be an
emergency authorization because there's
nothing else available which makes sense
okay and i would support if there's
nothing else available because at that
point you're taking the risk yeah it
makes total sense in a completely
unrelated note
a paper published in the lancet in may
of 2020 that said hydroxychloroquine
didn't work for covid was retracted
after the authors were unable to confirm
that any of the data
was accurate
[Music]
hmm also that part of the segment
completely unrelated you know the
vaccine mandate is for a lot of these
companies so you have to be mandated to
be vaccinated to vaccinate your
employees effects 100 or more which
affects over 80 million americans yeah
uh or a negative test once per week
every single person there are no tests
yeah go try and find some tests right
now
it's almost impossible about about four
weeks ago you could get them everywhere
get home tests everywhere i don't know
what happened and they're available
nowhere completely free completely
unrelated they're probably gonna make
you char you're probably gonna say hey
you have to go buy your own tests
well that's the problem and i think that
it was like 30 dollars when i bought one
a little while ago and that that really
is a problem you're just saying like oh
what it's not a big deal a lot of people
don't have money to pay for a test every
five minutes
right
i mean i do so you're just thinking
about it this way think about it this
way if you're doing the testing right
it's not one of those rapid tests right
there you're being they're being sent in
now somebody who has coveted who wants
to what is it a pcr test is that what
they're called the ones you send in they
have to wait on
50 million 20 million 10 million however
many people choose not to do this now
they have to wait on that can they
handle that capacity because mine took
over three days to come back which means
i could have been spreading all over the
place that's because you had to resend
it
on the stick what's spreading i thought
that's where you i thought that's what
you did yeah well no that's what that's
what you said you thought you did
he's always spreading him and tubing i
got that all right so let's before we
have vent shapiro on the show here this
is something i really wanted to talk
about today so right now this is this is
what we've been told is trust the
science
and by the way science is something that
changes at least if you're trusting
science not the science right but this
is a pandemic entirely of the
unvaccinated and we just had the
president basically wage war on uh
anywhere from a quarter to a third of
americans depending which statistics you
use
blaming this pandemic on people who
really initially according to the
science should have no effect on those
who are vaccinated so yeah this is also
not true and it's acknowledged to not be
true right now but let's start with the
blame game and the bone chilling thing
i've never been this scared for our
country
as when i listened to this speech live
from former vice president joe biden
this is not about freedom or personal
choice
my job as president is to protect all
americans
so tonight
i'm announcing that the department of
labor
is developing an emergency rule
to require all employers
with 100 or more employees
that together employ over 80 million
workers
to ensure their workforces
are fully vaccinated this is a pandemic
of the unvaccinated
and it's caused by the fact that despite
america having unprecedented and
successful vaccination program
despite the fact that for almost five
months
free vaccines have been available in 80
000 different locations
we've been patient but our patience is
wearing thin
and your refusal has cost all of us i
guess it's a good thing that nobody
gives a [ __ ]
how about that my patience is wearing
thin we offered it to you free yeah but
when you didn't take it for free we're
going to force you to do this this isn't
about your freedom or your personal
choice well if former vice president joe
biden says so no
this is this is the and what is this
department of labor
at the same time the cdc is the one who
basically bypassed the courts with the
eviction moratorium the center for
disease control is saying landlords
you're still on the hook for the
mortgage and renters doesn't matter if
you're michael keaton in pacific heights
you can't be kicked out yeah well he's
going around congress both times he's
going around congress both times and i
will say this look to people out there
now we have what a third of nurses yeah
a third of nurses who are going to walk
on this job
right now that's a labor shortage
that's some that is significant right
people are getting really upset with the
vaccine mandates and keep in mind that
that number is probably not going to
change much because a large portion of
people who are refusing to get the
vaccine are people who've already had
covet which is not even entered into
this equation former vice president joe
biden
it's vaccine what if i already had it
well you still got to get the vaccine
anyway but that's not common practice
that's not the norm here that's not what
the science tells us but fauci says we
don't really know so to be on the safe
side get a vaccine even though you
already had a virus even though we don't
necessarily know how your body reacts to
that if it's already fought off the
virus look this is right now everyone
out there
if you are working for a company
and you have chosen not to be vaccinated
for whatever reason and this is a choice
that everyone can make
uh i've advocated some people be
vaccinated who i think are at risk and i
think for some people they choose not to
and it makes sense for them just to be
clear i don't know who is vaccinated and
who is not in this office let me tell
you why because it's none of my business
just like the president has no right to
tell companies that they have to force
people to be vaccinated this is over 80
million americans
if you are in that company
and you don't want and you've chosen not
to be vaccinated don't do it
this is your line in this end i'm not
saying don't get vaccinated just because
you know i'm saying if you already chose
to do not allow this pressure to change
your decision
this is
far beyond the pale i've never
had the hair on the back of my neck
stand up as i did with at least barack
obama would cover it and talk about what
a great great nation this is yeah
it's not about your freedom or your
choice the people who just shrieked
about a heartbeat bill
which there can be no debate about the
fact that the law says you can't stop a
heartbeat that's not your own
all right and by the way all evidence
let's run through this really quickly
evidence shows that it's disingenuous
giving it as many as one-third
recent vaccinations are among the
vaccinations that we have unprecedented
results
right makes no sense it makes absolutely
no sense does one third one third of
america smallpox
is one-third of america a dock holiday
tv right now i'm your huckleberry and
this is all sources are available a lot
of credit to come i think the vaccine
does help in reducing caseload and
making it less likely to go to the
hospital let's be really clear yeah but
that's not why most people got no
they were told that they would not catch
it and so now people are saying well the
goal posts have changed
and you've changed where my freedoms
are allowed to be infringed so now you
get people who are more and more
uncomfortable um we actually have a
perfect example of a case study and this
is something that i found interesting
and uh hat tip to some there was some
message boards that talked about this
um
in june nbc and i remember the story
declared a victory for the blackfeet
nation the guy on your flight yeah uh
native american blackfeet nation
achieved a nightingale doctors i wear
flip-flops because my ancestors shopped
at paxon
so blackfeet nation they had achieved a
98 vaccination rate wow this is from nbc
the cbc also attributed a 33-fold
reduction in covid19 incidents in the
blackfeet nation from october 2019 to
november 2020 this is what they said
enforcement of state home orders and
mandated use of face covering the public
with potential fines in jail fines for
being unmasked so so that's great in
other words this was great this was 98
vaccination it was gone and this was
written about everywhere despite being a
small sample size which by the way i
will readily admit doesn't didn't stop
cnn uh sorry nbc from running on the
homepage except now
it turns out kovit's back and they've
had to reissue mass mandates what the
heck after cases have surged weird i'll
be darned that's so sad to hear and
actually our next guest probably knows
uh all about this we won't bring them on
right now but the data from uh from
israel is also reflecting a pretty
pretty damn concerning trend so very as
of august 31st i want to make sure i'm
reading this so i have it absolutely
right all sources are available at
ladders crowd.com all the references you
can go and read the entire articles for
yourself if you are unemployed or
retired
78 of israel's of uh eligible population
vaccinated
in august half of the 600 israeli
coveted cases had received two shots of
the vaccine
half of them in hospitals to be clear
now people say overall overall slower
sure but then israel was saying well
maybe we need to go with a third booster
that might actually need to be policy
right away in june the uk also reported
26 deaths among 4 087 cases of the fully
vaccinated from february june 2021
versus 34 deaths
in 35 000 cases amongst the unvaccinated
as of august 16th 60 of all gravely ill
coveted patients in israel were fully
vaccinated now i just came back from now
i'm not saying that when you look at the
data it seems like vaccines seem to
reduce the severity of it right but
that's not why most people out there
were vaccinated this is what matters the
goal posts move people weren't told hey
you'll get vaccinated it'll be a 50 50
shot but it won't be that bad yeah
well the difference between making your
own choice to get that vaccine and being
forced to by government that's really
what the problem right and i want to go
to your point real quick i know we have
ben shapiro coming up
um
so i was just at mayo by the way uh you
know i had the surgery and i have a cold
right now which caused me to sneeze and
i actually asked my my surgeon the head
of thoracic at mayo and i said hey uh
just so you know like i have a cold i
test a negative for covered but i'm
sneezing regularly and given that this
is post thoracic surgery my medical
question is um what's the most effective
way to kill myself and make it look like
an accident
and she was not i mean something about
hipaa i don't know
but um if you see me sneeze i don't i
just don't want to use a walther
sponsorship so just shoot me kill me in
any way that doesn't involve a wall
through told me it's if you see me start
to say it's a nine on ten it's the third
most painful it feels like every rib
breaking oh lord so anyways but mayo
they do their if anyone here wants to
say well that's flawed what i'm about to
tell you well it comes from mayo
this is a legitimate medical institution
the best i've talked about if you have
something wrong with you and people
can't figure it out go to mayo i can't
recommend them enough so
they did a study and to be clear the
quality of the study let me read this
cohorts of vaccinated and unvaccinated
individuals from minnesota 25
589 each
matched on age sex race history of prior
sars covid 2 pcr testing and date of
full vaccination so they separated 25
000 each fully vaccinated and not and
they found that the pfizer vaccine was
42 effective against a delta infection
in july
madonna did a little bit better that's
like a swiss cheese condom folks 42
percent
instead of
it's 58
not effective
i just want to be clear
and that's today by the way right we've
seen israel's a month or two ahead of us
is what they say we've seen this kind of
reduce time we'll see where it bottoms
out at but that's today or when the
study was done that's not yeah the mayo
study came from a little bit uh i think
about about a month ago about a month
ago yeah so you wonder why people might
be a little hesitant so you have a
country in israel there are a lot of
people there and then you have a study
with twenty five thousand minimum it's
big but might be fifty thousand as far
as uh actually if i'm reading this
correctly um
and that's
across a variety of race
races genders i don't even know if they
include a non-binary maybe that's the
wonder of natural maybe knowing it maybe
everyone at the vmas are immune true we
just didn't know
or anybody's benefit just shows up and
goes
or they have a little bit of everything
a little bit um everything i'm willing
to bet it's just a witch's brew
bill nos and gopher all right so this is
my question to you to everyone out there
look
if you've been vaccinating you guys can
comment below it's one of the best
things you can do for the algorithm
smash that like button
if you've been vaccinated
what has your experience been like if
you've not been vaccinated what has your
experience been like and i want to know
if you have caught covid or not whether
you are vaccinated or not just list your
status and what happened because we now
have a sample study of 50 000 people in
an entire country in israel and this
matters why does this matter because it
matters how you move forward in a
pandemic it matters the steps that we
take going forward if at least one of
the vaccines
is only 42 effective against the new
variant this matters it's not
anti-science to say hey
these numbers are alarming and science
is changing what do we do don't just
change the definition of protection from
a vaccination yeah
we need to figure out the most effective
way forward
but we can't because science has become
a religion and one of the tenets of that
religion is this is a pandemic of the
unvaccinated despite the fact that many
of you got that vaccine and you thought
well you know what at least i don't have
to worry about the unvaccinated because
i can't catch it well they're saying
that's not true now all right we're
going to talk about this and more with
my next guest who's coming up we have a
stinger ben shapiro
[Music]
mr shapiro
how are you sir is he is he playing call
of duty
wait is that is that stephen crowder
guys is he alive i'm i'm mostly alive
barely don't make them wow well
this does come as a shock to me i mean
frankly i thought that it was going to
be one of your co-hosts who was now the
host so well again i'm glad to see you
that's that's good you just put out
you just put out so many hits on random
gentiles you can't keep track and you
thought i was going to be
buried with those bodies in a shallow
grave by the way
don't be so lazy how i do this i like i
am somehow able to cave in chest walls
from abroad
it's very strong your mind powers you
did it with microwaves and gave me
havana syndrome
so um
this is something that's going around
right now i won't even talk about it no
and now i'm sick today uh uh no doubt
because of post-surgery my immunity is
probably compromised but no kovit it is
remarkable i have been sick three times
throughout this whole pandemic which is
rare for me and i still have not gotten
the kovid which is bizarre you're
immortal that's good yeah it's good to
know it is nothing can kill nothing can
kill steven crowder nothing they can put
a rod in his chest
he can get a really bad cold nothing
nothing kills me i have three rods in my
chest and they're actually titanium
because they're like you're a fat son of
a [ __ ] we can't just put steel rods in
here so i had to pay extra for three
titanium rods and i believe they're
bulletproof which we are going to put to
the test once i get the insurance uh
waiver so you do have a new book the
authoritarian movement
um
which is uh where is that available
right now yeah it's been that's been i
know you've been out of circulation for
a while but that thing's been out for
like six weeks dude yeah well yeah no i
i well it's it's i actually i have a goo
whatever the opposite is of a google
alert i have a google mute for ben
shapiro
it's just it's a smart move i actually
have one of those too because honest to
god i'm really annoying so yeah
yeah and then and then i also have one
for bing which i don't even use but it's
just for safe measure but then every now
and then because i have an old computer
because we don't all have ben shapiro
money that little son of a [ __ ] bent
back paper clip comes up like do you
know what ben's up to like oh
paper clip um so let me ask this last
week joe biden and that we just talked
about this announced that companies
with more than 100 employees have to
mandate the covet vaccine that i guess
so you at daily wire i don't know do you
have over a hundred you guys have over a
hundred yeah we have like 200 employees
yeah okay so
what are you guys going to do
so nope
the answer is no
uh the answer is that we have lawyers uh
at the ready uh and uh as soon as the
actual regulation drops and we'll have
to see you know what the legal analysis
actually looks like in terms of how you
filed a lawsuit but there's no question
we are going to be filing the lawsuit
because
there is no constitutional authority to
simply use osha rules to basically say
to every company in the united states
that you have to either get your crew
vaccinated or test them every week first
of all it's really ineffective policy i
mean i heard you mentioning a minute ago
um the the stats about natural immunity
which of course is very much true um but
it also happens to be the case that if
you are going to limit
if the idea here is that you have to
limit exposures by people to other
people you actually want to start with
small businesses not large businesses
right large businesses have a lot of
space like our offices are actually very
very sizable okay i see what's going on
here this is another example of too big
to fail the big guy ben shapiro daily
wire trying to [ __ ] the office with
15 people here it's not going to work
this is actually the point is that is
that for for joe biden the the goal here
is to actually benefit the biggest and
not the smallest right right meaning
that the mid-sized companies are the
ones who are who are going we're not
going to do this and it's like amazon
that's like sure we'll do that right
because amazon can afford to spend 50
bucks per employee per week right right
they can do that we have 200 employees
let's say half of them are not
actually vaccinated according to this
new mandate we're supposed to spend 50
bucks per week on every one of those
employees all 100 of those people it's 5
000 a week which is you know 20 grand a
month that's not like a tiny chunk of
change that's right over the course of a
year actually some fairly significant
money but put aside the money on
principle we're obviously not going to
do this because number one well i'm
astonished by the willingness to
undermine the efficacy of the vaccine
put out by this administration like i so
i got vaccinated pretty much as early as
it was possible to do so as you all know
i'm like a huge vaccine advocate i think
the vaccine is fantastic i think it is a
miracle of science and i think that
everybody but go ahead i i think i think
that it is i think it is fantastic i
think that everybody pretty much who's
above the age of 20 should should take
it i think if you're between the ages of
12 and 20 i think there's a good case
for one dose but not two i think if
you're below the age of 12 there's you
know then you start to get in real dicey
territory yeah i think that you should
you know assess your own risk however
because i'm an adult and you're an adult
and you get to make these decisions by
yourself right right in the same way
that everybody gets to make those
decisions by that was there was even a
case that that wasn't super true before
the vaccines but now the vaccines exist
you can take one and once you have taken
one you are now safe and it drives me up
a damned wall to see that all the people
who are the most worried all the people
who most want to control other people's
lives are the vaccinated that makes no
sense at all
but it does make sense when you
understand that the vaccine doesn't
protect you against for example the the
the delta variant when mayo shows that
it's only only 20 effective steven it
doesn't make any sense because it does
protect you against the things i care
about like i don't care if i get a flu
every year i don't care i take a flu
shot anyway but i don't care really if i
get a flu i don't care if i get a cold i
don't care about getting an infection
from a virus that is going to take me
out of work for one day i care about
dying and hospitalization and the same
thing for my parents right i care about
my parents dying i don't care about them
getting a diagnosis of covet i care
about them being hospitalized or getting
dead from cold these are the things that
i care about and the truth is that when
you look at the waning stats from israel
what you see for example with the pfizer
vaccine is that you're correct the
infection
protection against covet from the
physical vaccine went from something
like 90 down to about 40
but the hospitalization stats went from
about 98 protective to about 91 percent
effective and the death stats went from
about 99 effective to about 97 effective
so in other words you're not going to
die and you're almost
not and you're really not going to get
hospitalized if you take the vaccine the
reason that the numbers are higher among
the vaccinated in israel is because
israel's vaccination rates are so high
so that means that just of the
sub-population but a huge percentage of
people are huge
right and i remember just to
push back a little bit i remember a long
time ago on the show i said look the
number that matters and what you're
saying now effectively is deaths per
capita i said i don't care about cases
i don't care about uh when we're just
talking about hospitalizations because
those numbers can be manipulated right
because you can you have hospitals that
basically say all right we're going to
admit you look we're short staffed i
said the deaths per capita is a number
that matters and i remember you saying
well that number could end up changing
and so but i agree with you now i think
the deaths per capita are very important
and i think that that is an important
metric when we're dealing with the
vaccination uh i do think that it is
alarming however because the change of
the definition of success with the
vaccination and this is where we come
into a problem with the mandate right
where it was if you get the vaccination
you'll be protected again you won't
protect it against the virus meant you
won't get the virus and then they change
it and then say well you won't get
serious symptoms from the virus which
granted is is good it's a good thing my
issue here right now though too is this
whole vaccine discussion whether you're
pro-vaccine discussion or whether people
choose not to and i understand the
points that you're making
there is no treatment for people who
already have covet
and that's been politicized it doesn't
exist if you have covid right now and
you go to the hospital they say go home
come back and we'll toss you on a
ventilator and then anything that people
talk about is discussed as an
alternative treatment right we heard
that about hyperemectin hydro drugs i'm
not making any claims what i'm saying is
hold on a second alternative to what
it's not alternative to anything because
they don't give you anything there's a
few things that they're they're like
monoclonal antibodies are pretty
effective in the first couple of days
that you use them sure which was
dismissed as quackery last year it was
it was and then biden suddenly was
mentioning it right so stephen i'm
coming at the same point but from a
different angle than you almost an
opposite angle so my point is that if
your vaccine so joe biden said two
things in that speech that are in direct
conflict with one another he said if
you're vaccinated you're safe right and
then he said we need to protect the
vaccinated from the unvaccinated right
no
you don't no you don't right i'm
vaccinated i stop i literally stopped
caring about whether anyone around me
was vaccinated or masked or anything the
minute i got vaccinated right i stopped
caring about that literally that minute
my parents do right who are like i'm not
at serious risk so the truth is i wasn't
like super concerned i was gonna die
anyway i'm in fairly decent shape and
i'm young so i really wasn't that
worried but my parents are 65. and so i
was a little more worried about them and
i was in constant contact with them
throughout the pandemic but the minute
they got the vaccine it was it was katie
by the door i mean we went to big events
we were going out indoors like it was
over it was over for us right we were
done and it should be over for everyone
who's had the vaccine joe biden's policy
is specifically designed to not
accomplish that right this is the thing
that's amazing what joe biden is doing
is he's basically saying the reason that
the economy is tanking the reason that
that everything seems to be stagnating
is because of the delta variant that's
not true the reason that everything is
stagnating is because of your policy
decisions because here's the thing in
lots of states they have the delta
variant heavier than they do in delaware
or in new york or in dc the places joe
biden likes to hang out but those places
are wide open and they're not seeing
their economies tank the top 10 best
states in america for unemployment rate
are all red states except for vermont
the worst states in terms of
unemployment rate are all blue states
all of them so what that means is that
this is a policy question and joe biden
is trying to redirect your ire away from
him for shutting your life down and
making your life miserable and trying to
mask your kids and toward the
unvaccinated that's all this is right
because tomorrow like for me i've been
saying this for a while the pandemic is
over it's in in terms of public policy
it is not over in terms of like people
dying of coped that's the honest to god
it is now your choice whether you wish
to get a more serious form you're
getting immunity one way or the other
okay here's your choice you can get very
durable natural immunity which is better
than vaccine immunity by virtually every
study right and that comes with the risk
that you get a serious more serious case
of the disease right or you can get the
vaccine and you will get a mild illness
from covet if you get a breakthrough
case but you're getting back you're
getting the immunity one way or the
other there's no third choice where you
don't just get the immunity okay but
what that means is that now as a public
policy matter we have reached the end of
the pandemic okay there's there are no
more things to do and this is why what
you have seen from the left is a
consistent attempt to redefine to whom
is the risk so they're having a real
problem with this because they were
originally they were saying the risk is
among the unvaccinated and so we have to
do something and then all the
unvaccinated we're like yeah we know and
we don't care which is actually true
right everybody who's unvaccinated that
i know everybody i've talked to who's
unvaccinated is not worried about covet
the only people worried about kovid are
the people who should not be worried
about coven right the only people
unworried about kovid are the people who
maybe should be a little bit worried
about kobe right so it's completely
messed up and then so what so what does
the left decide on what they've decided
on now is the kids what they've decided
is that kids are highly vulnerable to
covet now the only problem is you have
to just lie right in order to make that
case you just have to lie you have to
lie that there are good studies we just
talked about
on cnn who's our medical analyst who was
the head of planned parenthood and she
wrote in january 2020 that the flu was
significantly more lethal to children
than covet we just we just quoted her
from the baltimore sun so did the cdc
and they changed that so now they just
have to lie and say this is a bigger
threat than the flu to young children
according to all of the long-term data
which let's just play it safe we don't
have long-term data liana when could
have been wrong back then and so could
the cdc but right now they're trying to
act as though definitively it's more
dangerous and it's a pandemic for young
people okay and by the way even if it
were you it the question matters if it
were more dangerous than the flu let's
assume that's the case how much more
are we talking 10 times more we're
talking 100 times more are we talking
like a little bit more right okay
because we don't shut anything down for
the flu so what they're also playing
with the numbers a little bit here in
the sense that the infection fatality
rate right the number of cases versus
the number of diagnosed cases versus the
number of deaths for this thing really
really low but if you have a really high
denominator you're going to have a
higher numerator right if you have a lot
more people who are affected by covid
because of delta you're gonna have a
higher number of kids who end up in the
icu but the grand total according to the
cdc today because i checked the numbers
this morning the grand total number of
people in the united states who have
died under the age of 18 across the
entire pandemic and this is a
sub-population of 73 million people
careful what you're about because just
so you know
we were not long ago gerald is looking
at me one of our videos one of our
entire shows was removed from youtube
for
putting the image on screen from the cdc
charts of the deaths from the flu in an
average year and deaths under 18 i
believe for covid that was the reason
that our whole episode got removed so if
that happens um well you know what
you're gonna you can blame me for that
we can build you we'll we'll
you and you and joe biden can bill me
for this but it's absurd but this this
is the big problem now too is is is you
can't fight back look you and i disagree
here but i don't think that anyone would
argue that either of our opinions here
have been medical misinformation we
simply talked about where the line is
between freedom and individual choice
something here that i think is pretty
important you know you just talked about
the tests right this this policy is you
mandate right it's a mandate you force
employees to be vaccinated or test them
every week have you tried to find tests
recently because i could get them three
weeks ago i can't get them within 50
miles of where i am today it's not
possible and when i ask these places
when are you going to get other tests
they say we have no idea it's changed
dramatically in the last
by the way this is also wildly
ineffective policy because let's say
that you test all these people once a
week why once a week
really why once a week yeah you can test
negative one day and two days later
you're positive you've now spread it to
the entire office and so you test it on
friday right like why also again just
like greg louganis on the diving board
at the olympics he tested negative and
then he was having a little fun in the
olympic village does a backflip hits his
head and no there's some hiv in the pool
i've always said that yeah that's yeah
anyway so
so here is so here is the
here is my main point and it's driving
me up a wall
there is no end goal that is actually
being named by any of your policymakers
not one of them will tell you what the
end goal is because their secret end
goal is zero coved and they know that
their secret end goal is not possible
everyone knows their secret end goal is
not possible when all is said and done
this is going to become endemic it's
going to come up every year there might
be a slight variation the variations
will likely get weaker over time because
that's what's happened with other
viruses and we now live in a world where
every adult above the age of 12 has the
capacity to get a vaccine and get nearly
bulletproof protection against death
which is the number that i care about
and hospitalization is pretty damned
good as well so what exactly are we
continuing to yell at people but
they're they're the real reason that joe
biden is doing this is twofold one is
that he has to distract from afghanistan
right he knows that this is
unconstitutional he knows it's likely to
get struck down he has to placate his
his left-wing base and he knows that
we're all going to yell about this and
then take our eye off the fact that he
just surrendered an entire country back
to the taliban and al-qaeda so
part of this is just complete wag the
covet misdirection
but
he kind of overshot it because it's so
dramatic the mandate that i it's almost
like well it's not really a wag anymore
this is on that same playing field
because this is really bad hold on uh
because of what you just said about the
cdc which could get us in trouble we're
going to continue this interview the
book is authoritarian movement but ben
shapiro uh he's a lawyer by the way he
is going to continue with us here on mug
club youtube thank you very much we
appreciate it but because we have to
actually discuss science and use the cdc
and world health organization as
resources uh right now you can piss off
[Music]